there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves I finally got my hands on
the house Labs Atomic Shake lip lacquer
this is another one of those transfer
proof glossy lipsticks this is
definitely like the hot new lip formula
so you shake the product well then apply
it the pigment in this really shocked me
it was so vibrant it almost looked neon
this went on so smooth I didn't need
more than one layer for full coverage
and it was so glossy I had to wait 15
seconds for what they called a shine
shield to form then I kissed the back of
my hand to see if I got any transfer and
nothing I've tried three lipsticks with
this kind of formula and so far this is
the best one this is the model ones
color Cube and bonfire amore it's a
solid gel cream palette it comes with
nine gel polishes and you can get them
in different color stories and finishes
it also comes with this little brush
I've used a solid gel cream before but I
forgot how thick it actually is so it
did take me some time to to apply it in
even layers I did have to do two coats
for full coverage on some colors I think
a product like this can be super
convenient especially if you do nail art
or just don't have the space to keep a
bunch of gel polishes around it doesn't
come with a base or top coat but I still
really like this I tested out a ton of
products from Jason Wu Beauty this is a
new brand for me so let's start with
what I didn't like this Frida brow was
too light for me which is my fault but
the formula on this is weird it feels
like an oily cream that never dries down
so I doubt it'll keep my brows in place
these stay in line lip liners weren't
great they were also too light for me so
I ended up using my own lip liner to
deepen it these are smooth but a little
too creamy they don't feel like they're
going to last very long on the lips at
all I also didn't like the woo Prime eye
the formula is so tacky and thick it
made my eyeshadow look patchy in certain
areas now on to the stuff I loved this
Flora four palette was surprisingly
pigmented and easy to blend I feel like
the primer is what got in the way of
showing you its full potential but I
still really liked it this blush Trio is
so gorgeous and Blended out really
nicely I used this ready to Shimmer
cream shadow as a highlighter and it
gave me the prettiest Golden Glow even
though it's not really meant for the
face this Jewel stick was incredible
look how much it brightened up my inner
Corners the honey fluff Lip Cream was
soft and comfortable on the lips
if you get anything from this brand get
this extra pout lip plumper oh my God
even if you don't care about the lip
Plumping aspect this is one of the best
lip gloss formulas I have ever tried
it's so cushiony and shiny and amazing
and everyone should get it the makeup
forever the professional mascara is
definitely a mascara it's nothing
amazing it has one side for lifting and
the other side for volumizing I didn't
get much of a lift but I did get a nice
amount of volume I just think there are
better mascaras out there for way less
money I am a huge fan of about face I
love so many of its products so when
these cheek freak blush bombs dropped I
snatched up three different colors I'm
just gonna say it I am so in love with
these I was nervous at first because
it's described as a blush balm which to
me sounded like it would break up my
Foundation but these Blended in so
beautifully it never moved the product
underneath even if my skin was already
powdered and the pigment on these is
unreal you can build them up however
much you you want I think these can work
for so many different skin tones they
are so so good I made the horrible
mistake of purchasing the winky Luxe
Saucy gloss four piece combo lip gloss
set this was made in collaboration with
Applebee's and the glosses are inspired
by its wing sauces you guys I thought
everyone was exaggerating when they said
the smell was making them gag but no
these smell got awful and it sucks so
bad because the color story is so pretty
and I could like see this concept
working had they just not added the
sauce since or even if they did
something like lemon pepper smells like
lemon Buffalo is just a spicy lip
plumper but no they went in this
direction we all bought it and talked
about it which is probably what they
wanted so I hope you're happy winky
looks you ruined four beautiful glosses
I tried out a new Foundation from Chanel
I actually wouldn't call this a
foundation it's more like a super
hydrating light tint it's very similar
to that rosing tinted serum I tried a
while ago so it has these pigment beads
that burst and spread as you apply it
this literally feels like nothing on the
skin there is little coverage but it
evens everything out nicely and it feels
hydrating I don't think this has a
strong staying power but it's still a
pretty tint for when you don't want to
do too much Chanel also has a blush in
this formula so I tested that out too I
actually blended it out on the back of
my hand before applying and tapped it on
with a sponge it took a minute to build
up the color but I think it's supposed
to look very natural it also didn't
break up the product underneath I'm
surprised by how much I liked these they
don't do too much but it's enough to
make a difference this is the Maybelline
Shadow blocks eyeshadow palette it's a
tiny stack of eyeshadows very similar to
the Kaja Bento trios the packaging is
pretty cheap one of my Shadows fell out
but it's okay I applied these without
any primer just to see how they perform
on their own they're actually pretty
pigmented Shadows I didn't have any
trouble blending them and the Shimmer
shade was pretty but overall I think
these are just okay I like the idea of a
palette like this more than the
execution everyone has been loving these
NYX jumbo lash lashes so I had to try
them even though I am terrible with
false lashes I thought the style ego
flare would look nice on my eye shape
and I was right these lashes made me
feel like a whole new person like these
are Disney princess eyes they were
pretty easy to apply and the band was
really comfortable I think these have
totally convinced me to wear lashes more
often this is the Urban Decay 24 7 Munda
shadow in Space Cowboy this is basically
a glitter Shadow this shade in
particular has been going viral it is
super intense and reflective but you can
definitely diffuse it to be more subtle
this formula is really smooth and easy
to work with however you want to use it
so I really loved this I did get some
glitter Fallout so I'd recommend using a
primer or leaving some powder under the
eyes while you're applying if you want
something more eye-catching and elevated
than a shimmer Shadow this is perfect
[Music]
foreign